a castel is a structure formed of human
people
it's a human tower
castels are a catalan tradition of over
200 years
today there are over 80 different
colliers or teams spread throughout
catalunya every two years we have a
competition the 12 best teams will
perform at the concourse in tarragona
i'm proud to be a member of the
castellis de vila franca the casteles de
billa franca have won the concourse for
seven consecutive times we hope to make
it eight consecutive victories
these are very big structures very big
castles and they require three or four
hundred people at a time to make these
kind of constructions
and they can reach heights of 15 meters
the most important thing of when we try
to make the castles is obviously the
safety of the people involved we have
very small children of the age of four
or five who will climb to the very top
of the castle everybody is working to
make sure that this is the safest
possible activity for them this is very
important because occasionally
castles will collapse
and it
looks spectacular but it can be very
dangerous it's quite common for people
to break a leg on arm shoulder injuries
as the castle progresses the pressure
builds everybody is trying to find a
little bit of oxygen in in the bottom of
the castle there have been times when
people are fainted or collapsed but you
still have to keep going because you
have the collective responsibility that
you don't want to let the team down
[Music]
you hear the final music that you know
the castle is completed you can relax a
little bit but you still have to
concentrate because this is the most
dangerous part of the castle because if
you relax too much the structure can
collapse very very quickly
why am i a castelli to be a friend
this is a very complex question and i
don't really have an answer you can't
explain it it's impossible to explain
you have to feel it if you feel it you
understand it
[Music]
you